[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we discussing Severus Snape
his ability to fly and the question was
he in animagus in the Deathly Hallows we
see Snape flying around quite a bit one
notable instance of this is when he
jumps from the tower
of the Hogwarts castle the following
passage depicts Snape flying in front of
McGonagall Harry and some of the
students
he jumped said Professor McGonagall you
mean he's dead Harry sprinted to the
window no he's not dead said McGonagall
he seemed to have learned a few tricks
from his master one issue that I have
with this passage is that mechanical
suggests that Snape learned flight from
Voldemort there is no evidence to
support this and she really didn't know
the ins and outs of his neighbors
relationship with Voldemort it was a
bold assumption for her to make if he
learned it from Voldemort then why
didn't all of the other Death Eaters use
it as well surely if he taught it to
Snape he would have taught it to
Bellatrix and Lucius I just don't
believe that he learned it from
Voldemort before I get into this further
one thing worth mentioning right away is
that in the films the Death Eaters can
fly but in the books they were never
able to it was an ability that was only
achieved by Snape and Voldemort JK
Rowling is reported to have stated that
all Wizards have the power of flight
innately but that the vast vast majority
need a broom to achieve it in Voldemort
case he was so focused and powerful that
he was able to channel the power to fly
unsupported harnessing the energy
through himself rather than the broom
perhaps named it the same but I really
think that he achieved it another way
one thing that we know for sure is that
the Death Eaters knew that Snape could
fly the following passage from Bellatrix
in the half-blood Prince confirms this
but you didn't return when he came back
you didn't fly back to him at once when
you felt the dark mark burn the fact
that they knew he could fly only
reinforces my instinct that he learned
it in a way that was different from
Voldemort surely if it was a skill that
was taught to him by father Mort the
other Death Eater
would have felt immensely jealous going
back to the first passage where Snape
jumps from the Hogwarts hour there's one
line that really piqued my interest I
think that it could shed some light on
his method of flying Harry saw a huge
bat like shape flying through the
darkness as far as the books are
concerned when Voldemort uses
unsupported flight he maintains his
original form so what's this bat like
shape
why would Snape resemble a bat my theory
for Snape appearing bat-like is that he
is actually an animagus assuming the
form of a bat when he wants to take
flight first of all Snape certainly
would have the motivation stemming all
the way back to his childhood Snape was
always locked into an immense rivalry
with the Marauders one thing that the
Marauders had in common was that they
could transform James Potter serious and
Pettigrew were all an Omega James could
transform into a stag Sirius a dog and
Pettigrew a rat even Lupin could
transform the result of him suffering
from lycanthropy so if his biggest
rivals could transform then why wouldn't
one of the most determined learners and
talented Wizards try to achieve it Snape
was incredibly tenacious patient and
strong-willed I can picture him now
spending hours and hours trying to
perfect this ability in an effort to
best his hated rivals he was the
half-blood Prince after all his office
also fit the bill as the perfect
environment for bat gloomy then we lit
and located in the school dungeon if you
aren't sold on that theory then another
explanation for the bat leg shape could
be the huge Transfiguration to turn his
arms into wings Snape was a gifted
wizard and he was once a student of
Horace Slughorn who is known to be
talented at Transfiguration this would
not have been out of the question for
him to achieve it may also better
explain why Harry saw a huge bat like
shape and not just a bat like shape what
do you guys think was Snape an
unregistered and Magus a talented
practitioner of Transfiguration or an
expert at unsupported flight let me know
down in the comments section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
you